it's this year big little lies a
marriage story little women do you feel
extra excited to see anyone in
particular tonight or it's just a night
with all your friends well a night that
all three of those projects are being
honored here at the producers guild
that's really all so deeply with so much
love produced by amazing people I was
gonna ask because look we know you're a
baby Yoda fan oh tyka is gonna be here
tonight and you know he knows baby
Yoda's real name and I'm just wondering
if you can get that out of him oh do you
Laura I think you know something you're
not telling us she's gonna keep his
secrets you seen big little lies
congratulations on your Oscar nomination
I mean what does it mean to be
recognized for your work in the film but
also to be part of two Best Picture
nominees I mean two Best Picture
nominees that I made last year with my
friends who are also a couple I spent a
year with is particularly special that's
what I love about Hollywood is when you
do get those moments where it's real
connections and people are telling their
real stories I gotta admit I wanted a
best directing nomination for Greta too
I don't how can we not she's an amazing
filmmaker and and she I know is thrilled
and I am thrilled that that she's
recognized for her incredible adaptation
as well as the movie and the acting in
the film so that's it's beautiful but
here's what we know the more opportunity
women have and the more diversity we
have both in front of the camera and
behind the camera the more opportunities
there will be to celebrate and to
celebrate female visionaries and
filmmakers and producers but we are here
Little Women is one of our nominees with
one producer as our as our producer of
Little Women Amy Pascal who's so
incredible so it's quite lovely and then
four big little lies it's my buddies
recently Bowl who are my producers so
it's you know
it's exciting to celebrate I gotta say a
lot of those opportunities for women
were provided by recent Nicole and big
little lies and of course everyone is
dying to know if a season 3 is happening
what can you tell us I will not not be
rich with my favorite meme up 20 I mean
she requires it and I love her so much
so I'm thrilled for her that she's a
meme because she would really appreciate
it and I could never say no oh so much
all right we are continuing here at The
Producers Guild of America Awards Teddy
this is a time when as we were just
saying with Laura so many people who are
both on camera and right behind the
scenes being honored tonight wearing
multiple hats because of course at the
PGA's they recognized what else
producers you know the masterminds who
are really responsible for getting these
projects because it's recognizing film
and TV not only getting the mail but
also seen and honestly they are also a
precursor to the Academy Awards yah ok
the producers guild awards have
predicted 21 of the 30 Best Picture
winner so it is a huge a huge award an
honor and in fact in case you are
unfamiliar with the Producers Guild of
America Awards here's exactly why they
matter take a look welcome to
Hollywood's most glamorous night of
nights the professional golf Producers
Guild of America Award season is in full
swing and the 2020 Producers Guild
Awards are not one to miss a movie is
not just the person who acts in it or
the person who wrote it or the person
who produced it it's the little people
like me that nobody ever gets to see
celebrating the finest producing work of
the year Octavia Spencer Marta Kauffman
Netflix's tatse randos the film
bombshell and Brad Pitt along with Dede
Gardner and Jeremy kleiner of Plan B
will receive special honors but the
award to keep an eye on is the coveted
producer of the Year award in theatrical
motion pictures the award is often a
strong indicator who will win Best
Picture at the Oscars in fact since the
producers guild awards started in 1990
this award has accurately predicted 21
of the 30 winners of the Academy Award
for Best Picture let's take a closer
look at the nominees 1917 Ford versus
Ferrari the Irishman
Jojo rabbit Joker knives out Little
Women marriage story once upon a time in
Hollywood and parasite
the only film in this category not
nominated for Best Picture at the Oscars
is knives out you guys fans I mean I
don't do much fiction reading myself big
fan in addition to recognizing film The
Producers Guild Awards the best of the
best and television and leaves no stone
unturned episodic limited series
non-fiction live shows sports children's
gaming competition and short form
programming are all categories for the
producers guild and new to the award
show this year the producers guild will
recognize VR AR and more experiential
mediums via their innovations award
winners will be announced during the
31st annual producers guild awards on
Saturday January 18th at the Hollywood
Palladium welcome back everybody i'm
lauren zima here with jenny direct oh
and Chernobyl star Jerrod Harrison his
lovely wife
Allegra thanks for being with us you
guys look amazing by the way now is a
night like this a little bit of a date
night out for you these work shows you
kind of show up a little hungry and
wonder where the food is such a long
journey to the PGA's for Chernobyl I
mean this is not the first suit you put
on for this project what does it meant
to be receiving so much love for this
amazing series it's been really
thrilling obviously because we were
really completely overwhelmed with the
way the show was received I mean you
know it was there's a fairly highbrow
show you know and it was just watched by
so many people just not in this country
but around the world so it really took
us by surprise what's sort of wild about
the show is its bin jabal which I know
they'd say I couldn't stop watching and
I watched episode after episode after
episode and it is also such heavy
material when you've had people come up
to you what do they say about their
experience that's fan I think they're
surprised but how moving it is and how
emotional it is and and also there's a
sort of there's an aesthetic beauty to
it as well which is Johan and his dpe
they're Swedish filmmakers and they have
that kind of that they're able to find
beauty in inter-entity and misery you
know so yeah I think people are
surprised by the the different elements
of it from the gold from the Emmys the
Golden Globes and now the producers go
to wards you know there's a you've been
rubbing elbows with a lot of folks it
has there been any celebrities or fellow
artists that you've been surprised we're
huge fans of the Chernobyl
I mean a lot Daniel Craig
all right congratulations again on the
show everything looks stunning don't
they will enjoy your alright coming in
now we have the unbelievable
incomparable Judith Light hello be right
to the camera that outfit shooting thank
you Hermes I was so excited to see both
you and Bette Midler at the end of the
politician I need a buddy cop comedy now
I know it's really it's really you know
but that's all so that's Ryan Murphy's
brilliance and in putting people
together
he knows what chemistry can work so
anywhere having a great time so I flew
in overnight yeah to be here in this
afternoon I have a new thing coming out
on spectrum were originals and Lionsgate
which is called manhunt Oh deadly games
it so we were doing the TCS all
afternoon you've been busy
but this night is a great night where
people really get recognized for being
behind the camera as well and I think it
feels like such a close tonight for
Hollywood give me a way is it just
tonight a friends anybody you're looking
forward to seeing well I'm looking
forward to seeing my friend Thomas Cale
who you know they're nominated for a
fauci gurgles
so I'm looking forward to seeing Tommy
and my good friend Susan strong and
there are a bunch of other people that
I'm sure I'm gonna find as the night
goes on
so freeze your date tonight my husband
he's down over there okay are you guys
coming up on 35 I think we actually just
celebrated our congratulate each of you
and the politician in the last two
episodes one word you use to describe
what you know all I can tell you is
really smart it's really great writing
it's great directing and it's great all
the dynamics in front and behind the
camera are spectacular thank you so much
all right so Judith Light celebrating 35
years I should have asked her the secret
to marriage I just find you though one
rubbing elbows with here on the red
carpet but also if he doesn't want to
show up you are happy to go home to him
you know I mean I just answered the
question for Joe okay so we've got some
of the stars of book-smart coming down
the carpet we will have more as The
Producers Guild Awards continues even
she's hiding right back here for you how
are you holding up and powering through
award season you were at the Globes
you're hitting them all has it been well
you know I've always judged people who
say like it's fine but now
I fully get it you can ask the same
questions a bunch so I'm just gonna dive
in with it again are we gonna get the
book smart sequel I want it we all want
book smarter book smarter seats really
written there you go I mean the chance
to get to Feeny again would just be
amazing so I love her so morning
what would you envision they go to
college well yes we end up going to
college at the end but maybe it's like
an after college situation or I don't
know if she comes and meets me and
Africa Spring Break yeah it was amazing
that the Golden Globes is that all your
friends were there too what was that
night like it what has this award season
meant to you knowing that your friends
are also being recognized for their work
it's been such a special year for me as
a person but then to also be able to to
share that with some of my closest
friends and you know being at the Golden
Globes is such a nerve-racking like
thing that I've looked up to like I've
looked at the goal I've watched the
glows my entire life and then I was
there and it's just nice to have those
people that are so close to me and and
to be able to like you know hold hold
their hand and it was great and it makes
more fun it makes it so much more fun my
friend Margaret calling like spanked me
is on the carpet as she was walking by
it she just like hey it was great it
just made it just made the nerves go
away did you have any oh my god
starstruck moments of the Golden Tate I
as we were filing out after the Globes
everyone was heading out and Tom Hanks
national treasure timing and he told me
to like hold his gold and he gave me his
Golden Glove and said like I know I've
turned around my parents witnessed
everything and I just like put my head
in my hands I've never had a reaction
like that before it was really crazy
those are the moments you can't plan for
I mean I'm sure you can predict you'd be
at the Golden Globes let alone meeting
Tom Hanks like I know I won't makes like
stopping looking at me get Al Pacino
here tonight
did you just celebrate a birthday thank
this crazy year you've had made you
think about what you wouldn't want to
accomplish this year any goals of people
to work with our types of projects you
want to do I think you just want to
continue to tell really great complex
stories for women and because I feel
like I was able to do that with book
smart and unbelievable and I was able to
not only do what I love but also move
people in a different way than I have
before so I wanted to I really want to
continue to do that for sure
ya know attended I'm so good to see
actually she's really amazing you enjoy
is actually a special honoree tonight
she's receiving the visionary take a
statin graduations on this amazing honor
obviously you have been a working actor
for a very very long time and now as a
producer you're bringing a lot of
important stories to light what does
that mean to you well what I am sharing
tonight in the room for the first time
to the industry is my dream was to be a
producer before an actor so the fact
that I'm getting to see that dream
realized is really exciting and it's
important to me that's unusual usually
people the other way around
you know what made you get into acting
that instead of continuing to pursue
produce that's amazing and it is so cool
when you see people who have been both
behind the camera and in front of it
what do you think that doing those dual
roles does for you in producing or in
acting and how do you how does it help
you to understand them well it makes me
understand just how privileged I am to
have the opportunity to get to do what I
love to do I am seeing my dreams
realized both in front of and behind the
scenes and I started behind the scenes
so I as a producer want to make sure
that I avail myself to other
storytellers and creators to see their
and obviously there's always a lot of
talk especially now about diversity and
inclusion youthful responsibility to
bring diverse filmmakers and people
behind the cameras and as well as
diverse story interesting thing I mean
if people look outside of themselves and
at the world at large and allow for
different voices to come into their zone
then it would be inclusive and you would
see a broad spectrum of who we are as a
world and I think we get so closed off
into our little zones of people that we
you know I don't think it's an
intentional thing but yeah we adore you
we can't wait to see you in there
congratulations on the award
next up mr. Nyes coming in so much just
celebrates it and anybody you're looking
forward to seeing this is just kind of
also a night of friends getting together
yeah I'm always with these things I'm
just sort of like a it's kind of amazing
it's really nice to sort of represent a
film as well that has been nominated and
just have everybody who works on it feel
that their work is getting recognition
and I mean does it feel like an
embarrassment of riches because
obviously you are a perfect it TV show
outliner and then to be part of a film
that's being recognized in this way not
just by producers guild but also the
Academy I mean what does that feel like
yeah this does not happen very often so
it's very exciting it's very cool
I mean I loved being part of the film it
was so much fun to fennel them and it
was so much fun to work with Christian
and with Jam and with Matt so yeah this
is good cool these are good days I loved
the movie and it's just also this movie
where it's this big great movie to see
in a theater with these big stars did
you I don't know if you'd worked with
Christian or Matt before but did you
have favorite movies of theirs and did
you have to discuss anything with
I mean I pretty much I think I've seen
probably nearly everything Christmastime
I mean he's just he's such a class act
and he's such a talent and not as well I
mean I don't know it's I was very
intimidated I think the first day but
they're both the most normal like just
family guys that when you meet them they
just put you at ease and we all got
stuck into the work it was really fun
you know we're we're trying to ask as
many people as we can tonight this is
one of those nights where you see the
hustle that people are put into
everything was there a time in your
career when you got a no and if so how
did you push past it you learn from it
and move on and I will say you got a big
yes with Outlander I can't let you leave
it again some tea from season five
because obviously you know Claire is
kind of at a crossroads and so I know a
lot of fans out there I think the
question for you is whether or not you
think Bri and Roger should stay in the
past or return to their own time oh
that's a hard one well I think Claire
feels that I think she she wants them to
go back I think she feels that they
would be safer and they would be happier
there but it breaks their heart to say
that Katrina things they should stay all
right Outlander the fans are so rabid
when it comes to that show and I think a
lot of people needed to know some plot
points so there you have we saw Rian
Johnson I think sneak in or oh he's meet
right here which I sure would grab to
you producer Jojo rabbit also snuck in
also director I mean he wore a lot of
hats for that film also recognized by
the Academy just this past week we had a
run-in I got to tell you there are so
many amazing projects are be recognized
including bombshell bombshell actually
is receiving a special honor tonight
recognizing a film that illuminates
provocative social issues now of course
the film is also nominated for three
Oscars and in case you haven't seen it
yet here's why bombshell is not amazing
someone has to speak up someone has to
get met Margot
Shirley's Nicole you have these
powerhouse women who are coming forward
to tell a story about sexual harassment
that story is bombshell the movie about
the Fox News scandal that expose
misconduct by the late Roger Ailes
thanks to gretchen carlson played by
Nicole Kidman and megyn kelly by
Shirley's bear the fact that we made
this movie is a miracle it's so
rewarding for all women because it shows
that we care about this issue enough
this is before Harvey Weinstein before
me - in times up what's really going and
so it felt like a story that was living
in its own silo and yet look at us two
years later and so I yeah i mean i'm i
do sync this movie and some weird way
will be a historical marker for this
movement but it's not just that impact
that has audiences talking char lisa's
uncanny impression of megyn kelly has
some of the biggest buzz of award season
think of actors in this creative
storytellers we try to do all of this
with blood coming out of her wherever I
go did he just accuse me of increments
trading I can't speak to the job
Charlize Theron did because I'm just too
close to it I just it's just too weird
to see somebody who looks just like you
on the screen pretending to be you then
there's Margot Robbie's Caleb if this
movie shows anything I hope it shows
that we're stronger when we stand
together I think I'd be freaking
phenomenal on your network but I need to
know that you're loyal
I need you to find a way to prove it
while Kayla may not be a real person her
infamous spin scene was reminiscent of
something very real for the women of Fox
News so I was asked to do the spin yeah
and God help me I did it I remember
feeling like I put myself through school
I was offered partnership at Jones Day
one of the best law firms in the world I
argued before federal courts of appeal
all over the nation I came here I'm
covering the United States Supreme Court
I graduated with honors from all of my
programs and now he wants me to twirl
and I did it so now thanks to bombshell
the truth is out there I don't think any
of us set out to go make a sympathetic
film because women don't deserve that
and do women don't want that we just
want the truth to be so we want to be
heard and but there's still more work to
do thought we had beat this but we
hadn't but now we're going to ready to
go to war oh yeah
welcome back everyone i'm lauren zima
here with deney direct oh we are the
official live streaming pre-show for The
Producers Guild of America Awards and I
am joined now by oh the president's
themselves yes Gayle Berman and Lucy
Fisher thank you guys for being here
what a night how excited are you
we were just saying it's such a big
award season period so many great films
and huge stars in them anybody who you
really are excited to hear take the
stage and hear from them with their
speeches tonight honestly we have a lot
of favorite films this year I mean it's
really kind of amazing and we're a
little bit starstruck so I'm like I like
seeing lots of people here so we've got
Brad Pitt here all right I will say the
PGA's have predicted 21 of the last 30
Best Picture winners I mean no pressure
right what's the crystal ball telling
you guys is there a film that you think
is gonna take it all the way come on son
means you know that the producers guild
really is kind of a huge precursor to
the Oscar so it's kind of exciting to
have a live stream going out there so
that people can behind-the-scenes of
putting a film together so all of these
major motion pictures have producers
eight of them have women producers were
really happy to say so it's very
exciting night for us all right everyone
Brad Pitt has hit the carpet here at The
Producers Guild Awards I mean looking
snazzy no pun intended but he really is
Benjamin Button I mean he is grand hit
the red carpet it's also amazing because
it's been a huge year for number once
upon a time in Hollywood he's been
recognized by the hfp a for the Golden
Globe produces we are live live
streaming ahead of The Producers Guild
Awards and congratulations on the honor
tonight how are you finish oh it's nice
you know I'm really proud of the work
we've been at this for maybe 17 years
and the films have been able to put out
so everyone else you know give you
credit sir because you've been having
some fun this award really people loved
your Golden Globes speech oh good
I mean at this point your career because
obviously that you're no stranger to the
award circuit and you've been part of
such amazing films what does it mean to
be recognized in this way from Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood with your pals Leo
and Quentin well you know you never know
what's gonna land it's always fun when
the film really speaks to to a wide
audience you know anymore the older I
get the experience is every bit as
important and those guys it was a good
Brad you kind of joked on a podcast you
said your life's a bit of a disaster but
it does ever seen at the Maron show how
have you been celebrating I mean your
family know you you gave your mom a
little shout out at the globe so have
you been celebrating this great year and
all the recognition with the family with
the kids you said you're gonna start
dancing right after a long break from
and where are you trying to dance Brad
Bradley Cooper that shout out to he's
been important
alright Brad thank you congratulations
all right we also have miss Charlize
Theron here on the carpet of The
Producers Guild Awards just stunning in
black and white they just take and look
at where Shirley's is wearing because
this this is a woman who I think has a
rack lined up for one season and every
time it is killer it's amazing she's a
little blind lights blinded by the
lights our bombshell Charlize Theron
here so Brad gonna be again getting that
special award tonight she'll also
getting
Athy Producers Guild of America Award
again bombshell is actually receiving
special honors tonight for being a film
that really illuminates as they put it
provocative social issues and no one did
as beautifully as Charlize as megyn
kelly and because the Nostalgia worn off
yeah you know hitting these red carpets
and obviously you've been so amazingly
recognized throughout award season for
bombshell with the producers and we just
it's special concern sometimes it feels
like a very long road to get a picture
like this made I have to ask you the
funniest story the other night about
you're talking about somebody who who
asked you to make out with your nose
you're such a good storyteller and you
have fun during awards season what's
kind of the secret just surviving is it
just laughing through all these shows
personal life's a disaster but luckily
awards season right exactly uh you know
I gotta ask you obviously megyn kelly
shared her reaction after seeing
bombshell and it kind of made you
emotional why was that
this all happened to them you know we
made the movie about it and I acted all
in that stuff but this actually happened
to all of them and to hear them reflect
on it and talk about it and and to just
hear these continuous stories of how
pervasive sexual harassment is in the
workplace it's emotional yeah and the
Oscar nominations for the movie for you
I mean what was that like to hear
utter shock yeah I mean listen hey I'm
blown away by all the love that we've
been getting for the film and I'm super
grateful for all of it because for those
of you who make these kind of movies you
know how hard it is to just get people
to talk about it but this one seems to
get people really wanting to share and
talk about it feels really good does it
make you want to tackle any other
real-life stories what is next for you
in terms of what you want to do I'm
taking a break
you are production
we're so our slate is so full anyway I'm
never not gonna work but I need to just
take a moment will that break include
binge watching The Bachelor I think you
have some episodes to catch up on unless
you've been watching in real time like
the rest of us season off to a wild
start have any favorites yeah there's a
lot I don't know their names yet so
champagne girls grades Kelsey sorry
Kelsey I'm gonna get there it's not year
I'm just bad with names the other Hannah
is that's gonna be interesting and I'm
and I'm putting money down that Hanabi
he's gonna show up Aaron I mean you can
do the Oscars you can do the bachelor
you can do it all okay we've had harvey
keitel hit the carpet we are also seeing
Kate Beckinsale looking stunning in
sequins
you're the producers guild war gonna
growing and no ball back behind us are
those two I mean the award season couple
of the year considering they are both
hit here with Best Picture nominees for
the Oscars here at The Producers Guild
Awards and you know they both put Laura
Dern in their project
I know 100% I mean it's all insane I
wonder if they have money on which film
of theirs is going to actually take on
the best picture whether or not they're
even competing to begin with but it is
obviously a very special special season
for Greta carpets and we are closing in
on Showtime beginning soon I loved
hearing some of the stories Octavia
Spencer saying she always wanted to
produce before she even began acting
she's getting the visionary award here
tonight that was kind of amazing to hear
because you look at her IMDB page and
she has been in film since I believe was
1992 and she has been a actors actor and
working and pounding pavement it's kind
of hard to believe that her first dream
was to produce but it's kind of amazing
the power and the magic of a Hollywood
dream you were talking about how the
producers guild awards has predicted the
last 21 out of 30 Best Picture winners
and just looking at their list they have
given 10 movies in their category for
Best Picture The Producers Guild Awards
they always do 10 the Oscars do 9 so
they're only one-off not their lists are
exactly the same so we'll see tonight
could be a big indicator for where we
end up with the awesome and among those
nominees the irishman and we have the
star close get cozy see you guys
the movie has just gotten unending
acclaim did you have any idea when you
were making it how much people would
love it and how much it would be all
over awards season we certainly hope
iconic to see the incredible talent and
I mean I covered the premiere with you
guys and to see all of you there
together
it's just unparalleled talent was it
unforgettable to work on that movie with
that group of guys you've known for so
long I would just like to say hello to
uncle Richie
hi uncle Richie he's a fellow
Brooklynite okay
what has it meant to you to be able to
kind of share this experience with all
those legends and your pals but also
some pals in the industry like Quentin
Tarantino he's also obviously being
recognized as well for his work this
year Quentin knew well these are great
talents and it's always great to
celebrate the work and that's what we're
doing
I feel like when they talk about movies
and the awards show contenders you can
tell they've seen it all they watch
every movie and movies movie three one
thing you can do take a step back
these guys are brilliant and that fun
great sense of humor but both of them
and can I ask you what's one thing we we
would be surprised to know about Quentin
in particular you they raided your
fridge inside your refrigerator
thank you enjoy your evening it's a
legend that's the truth by the way we
believe yet they are coming in Fast and
Furious now of course some of the people
behind parasites we are I have to tell
you that movie Danny I watched it I
didn't sleep for two brilliant I gotta
tell you parasite those one of those
films this year that was word of mouth
it's spread like wildfire and obviously
it's been recognized in a huge way by
the Academy with the Best Picture
nominee nomination also won for who
you're seeing right here boom joon-ho
the director of parasite he of course
took home the Golden Globe this year so
it's a big big year for bongju home and
what I love about that movie is you
don't notice that you're reading it you
know the acting in that movie you can
understand everything that they're
saying even if you don't speak the
language we'll see if he wants to come
over all right well we are here
recognizing your incredible work again
for you it's been conversation and now
to have your film up against Todd
Phillips film Joker for best picture I
mean that must feel surreal wouldn't
need to wake up to six Oscar nominations
Borden gets home Anika Golden Glove more
Critics Choice not on Oh Lord Simon to
kill scanning Oscar De Niro so now to
get Hermann Gunkel about the humidity at
sea no lecture
for me and also all Korean industry yeah
she'll go nearly captured Sebastian and
the Kim ego two years ago I'm an annuity
man
yo neva neva Rogers Anika until gonna
return waterfall that's just pouring
into me but we don't make films for that
but when it happens it's great and this
might not be the last time we see
parasite we've heard that it might be a
series on HBO now you're working with
Adam McKay on it what can we expect so
Jung in on your wisest chance with young
Dae Shannon gonna go mighty in the
manner that you do Teresa so Adam McKay
you i'm kim i hope you korres oh yes oh
she can tell you what a mandolin the
king could happen in this story so i
want to create like a six hour film and
give all those ideas to Adam McKay
that's incredible movie extended movie
here fraid we want to see it parasite a
Snow piercer what is the next idea that
you want to tackle do you have your next
big one percolating already I'm going in
there in there monkey that it to you now
but please wait a little you're teasing
us are all eyes on you congratulations
on everything thank you guys very very
much
all right everybody we were speaking to
Brad Pitt just a few moments ago he is
getting an award here tonight his
production company Plan B and it's been
quite an awards season for Brad period
let's take a look at the journey he's
been on what would it mean to win
tonight it's such a subjective thing
this time of the year we all get to come
together see we don't see each other all
year we all go off in foreign
and make these things and we had to come
together and say hey I really like your
work and after that it's been a big year
for Brad Pitt
it's what a year for you to fabulous
pieces of cinema will you be done after
this for the year get to put it away yes
get on to other things making some new
things making scripts keep making the
a-list star released two critically
acclaimed movies back to back I do what
I do because of my dad
she'd give you slice and a piece of
knowledge
because up there is where our stories
can be told ad astra which debuted in
August at the Venice Film Festival it
was pretty special and of course once
upon a time in Hollywood which premiered
at the Cannes Film Festival in May
did you know you broke the Internet okay
that speak for you're doing good babe
sure fans couldn't stop talking about
the 56 year old sexy shirtless roof
scene and what's got you so upset man
but it was his performance alongside
Leonardo DiCaprio that quickly gained
him some serious awards buzz about
working with Leo he's a good egg you
know we come through the same circle
I really admire his taste one of the
best tantrums ever laid down in film I'm
just gonna leave it at that
you and Brad your chemistry in this
movie is next-level it's so special how
did you guys just make that magic
actually you know it really came
naturally and it was one of the more
easy sort of natural fits that I think
I've ever experienced the role earned
Brad Best Supporting Actor nods at the
Critics Choice Awards Screen Actors
Guild Awards Golden Globes and the
Academy Awards and if that weren't
enough perhaps production company Plan B
will be honored with the David Selznick
Achievement Award at the producers guild
awards Brad has been nominated for an
Oscar five times in the past
in 2014 he took home his first and only
Academy Award for 12 years a slave a
film he produced this is a film that
will that has legs that will that will
be around to be speaking to people for
for many many years and and that's the
biggest prize but no matter what happens
at this year's Oscars Brad is taking it
all in stride do you ever like worry the
next thing no no no I mean I feel pretty
privileged and and you know it's there's
a shelf life on this thing hopefully we
have other things going for us there's
no shelf life on you Brad Pitt because
you're on top of the roof fixing the
satellite TV in a little
surely see they probably clean that one
up I don't know
thank you though The Producers Guild of
America Awards going down here tonight
at the Hollywood Palladium in Hollywood
California I'm Lauren seam and I'm Dani
director as you could tell Brad Pitt has
been having so much fun
this season being recognized of course
for his working on Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood and it's something we got to
see up close and personal when we talked
to Brad just a moment ago we are live
live streaming ahead of the producers
guild awards and congratulations on the
honor tonight we give you credit sir
because you've been having some fun this
award really people loved your Golden
Globe I mean at this point your career
because obviously you're no stranger to
the award circuit and you've been part
of such amazing films what does it mean
to be recognized in this way for Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood with your pals
Leo and Quentin well you know you never
know what's gonna land it's always fun
when the film really speaks to to a wide
audience you know anymore the older I
get the experience is every bit as
important and those guys it was a good
Brad you kind of joked on a podcast you
said your life's a bit of a disaster but
it does have ever seen seen at the Maron
show well how have you been celebrating
I mean your family know you you gave
your mom a little shout out at the
Globes how have you been celebrating
this great year and all the recognition
with the family with the kids
right interview said you're gonna start
dancing again right after a long break
and what are you trying to dance Brad no
you know I still love you give him
Bradley Cooper that shout out to he's
been important thank you congratulations
Brad Pitt being honored tonight and we
have to say goodbye to one of the
biggest shows of the last decade Game of
Thrones it's gonna get some love tonight
at The Producers Guild of America Awards
goodbye it's been a very long goodbye
but this really is the swan song for the
HBO hit series and in fact let's take a
look back at Game of Thrones a huge
impact it's officially the end of an era
oh my goodness
Game of Thrones is wrapping up its last
ever awards season
the quest for one throne has given us
eight seasons 73 episodes and of course
launch the careers of some of the
biggest stars in Hollywood this show has
been more than a decade of your life how
are you preparing for it all to end it
kind of in some ways has ended for us
you know we finished when we finished
filming we we say goodbye to it so it's
this is sort of just seems like an added
bonus that we're getting to watch it and
celebrate it now I don't I'm it son kind
of I said to Rose the other night I was
like we've been tethered by this show
for a long time we've loved it and now
we get to enjoy the final one of those
last Faraz could happen at the 2020
producers guild awards the show's
producers are nominated in one of the
biggest categories of the night feels
pretty damn great it's such a huge show
the cast is so big they're so
many people work on it you know the fact
that we have this much recognition for
it is fantastic since its premiere in
2011 Game of Thrones has become the most
nominated primetime scripted drama in TV
history with an impressive 160 Emmy
nominations duty has a grand total of 59
Emmy wins including Outstanding Drama
for their eighth and final season and
the Emmy goes to Game of Thrones
while Peter Dinklage is the only person
from the series to have won a Golden
Globe the entire cast is nominated for
outstanding performance by an ensemble
in a Drama Series at this year's a SAG
Awards it was so strange because if it's
ever been so long since we've all been
together the stars may be ready to party
it up but what do they really think
about the fate of the Iron Throne stop
being so obsessed bloody Iron Throne
yeah yeah I know and it causes so much
conflict and I just think let's just
what cool debates it's just a light
matter I guess the problem with the Iron
Throne no one knows she deserves it you
know nothing Jon Snow well one thing we
do know is we're gonna miss seeing this
cast all together on the red carpet I
hate to sound cliche but I'm not over
the end you're not are you sad it's over
of course that was a show where you felt
like those characters were your friends
I was on for so many years and we
followed it so closely we're moving into
a new decade and it's kind of the end of
an era with Game of Thrones but glad to
see it getting record end of an era and
I gotta say I'm also it's kind of said
we're not gonna see them on the carpet
together anymore we're going to follow
their social medias you see what they're
doing and hanging out because obviously
they became friends and fast family on
that show but this is really the end of
award season for them yeah well we are
winding down with The Producers Guild of
America Awards red carpet here but we've
seen so many famous faces Kate
Beckinsale is here Brad Pitt is here
we're expecting Robert DeNiro Al Pacino
Michael KITT Nicole Kidman idina menzel
is performing tonight and some of these
special honorees include Octavia Spencer
Reese Witherspoon will be here getting
recognized for big little lies and so
much more but we had to talk to of
course the bombshell herself take a look
at what Charlize Theron had to say I
mean wait you have to ask who you're
wearing you look on
and because the Nostalgia worn off yet
you know hitting these red carpets and
obviously you've been so amazingly
recognized throughout award season for
bombshell with the producers and we just
yeah it's special concern sometimes it
feels like a very long road to get a
picture like this made it does not
always feel like it is I have to ask you
I saw the the funniest story the other
night about you're talking about
somebody who who tasked you to make out
with your nose you're such a good
storyteller and you have fun during
awards season what's kind of the secret
just surviving is it just laughing
through all these shows anything
personal life's a disaster but luckily
award season right exactly uh you know I
gotta ask you obviously megyn kelly
shared her reaction after seeing
bombshell and it kind of made you
emotional why was that
this all happened to them you know we
made the movie about it and I acted all
of that stuff but this actually happened
to all of them and to hear them reflect
on it and talk about it and to just hear
these continuous stories of how
pervasive sexual harassment is in the
workplace it's emotional Dan and the
Oscar nominations for the movie for you
I mean what was that like to hear I'm
blown away by all the love that we've
been getting for the film and I'm super
grateful for all of it because for those
of you who make these kind of movies you
know how hard it is to just get people
to talk about it but this one seems to
get people
wanting to share and talk about it so
that feels really good
does it make you want to tackle any
other real-life stories what is next for
you in terms what you want to do I'm
taking a break
you are production
we're so our slate is so full anyway I'm
never not gonna work but I need to just
take a moment will that break include
binge watching The Bachelor I think you
have some episodes to catch up on unless
you've been watching in real time like
the rest of us off to a wild start have
any favorites yeah there's a lot I don't
know their names yet so champagne girls
great Kelsey
sorry Kelsey I'm gonna get there it's
not year I'm just bad with names the
other Hanna is that's gonna be
interesting
and I'm and I'm putting money down that
Hannah being is gonna show up at some
but then people think they're saying
proposals showing up a proposal and
she's throwing a whole spanner in the
wheel I'm good too Erin I mean you can
do the Oscars you can do the bachelor
you can do it all thank you enjoy the
Uni then congratulations someone has to
speak up someone has to get miss Largo
shirley's Nicole you have these
powerhouse women who are coming forward
to tell a story about sexual harassment
that story is bombshell the movie about
the Fox News scandal that expose
misconduct by the late Roger Ailes
thanks to gretchen carlson played by
nicole kidman and megan kelly by
Charlize Theron the fact that we made
this movie is a miracle it's so
rewarding for all women because
it shows that we care about this issue
enough this is before Harvey Weinstein
before me - in times up what's really
going and so it felt like a story that
was living in its own silo and yet look
at us two years later and so I yeah i
mean i'm i do sync this movie and some
weird way will be a historical marker
for this movement but it's not just that
impact that has audiences talking char
lisa's uncanny impression of megyn kelly
has some of the biggest buzz of award
season actors in this creative
storytellers we try to do all of this
with blood coming out of her wherever I
go did he just accuse me of increments
trading I can't speak to the job
Charlize Theron did because I'm just too
close to it
I just it's just too weird to see
somebody who looks just like you
on the screen pretending to be you then
there's Margot Robbie's Caleb if this
movie shows anything I hope it shows
that we're stronger when we stand
together I think I'd be freaking
phenomenal on your network but I need to
know that you're loyal I need you to
find a way to prove it
while Kayla may not be a real person her
infamous spin scene was reminiscent of
something very real for the women of Fox
News so I was asked to do the spin yeah
and God help me I did it I remember
feeling like I put myself through school
I was offered a partnership at Jones Day
one of the best law firms in the world I
argued before federal courts of appeal
all over the nation I came here I'm
covering the United States Supreme Court
I graduated with honors from all of my
programs and now he wants me to twirl
and I did it
so now thanks to bombshell the truth is
out there I don't think any of us set
out to go make a sympathetic film
because women don't deserve that and the
women don't want that we just want the
truths to beat so we want to be heard
and exactly but there's still more work
to do
thought we had beat this but we hadn't
but now we're going to ready to go to
war oh yeah she's on this amazing honor
obviously you have been a working actor
for a very very long time and now as a
producer you're bringing a lot of
important stories to light what does
that mean to you well what I am sharing
tonight in the room for the first time
to the industry is my dream was to be a
producer before an actor so the fact
that I'm getting to see that dream
realized is really exciting and it's
important to me that's unusual usually
people it the other way around you know
what made you get into acting then
instead of continuing to pursue produce
that's amazing and it is so cool when
you see people who have been both behind
the camera and in front of it what do
you think that doing those dual roles
does for you in producing or in acting
and how do you how does it help you to
understand them well it makes me
understand just how privileged I am to
have the opportunity to get to do what I
love to do I am seeing my dreams
realized both in front of and behind the
scenes and I started behind the scenes
so I as a producer want to make sure
that I avail myself to other
storytellers and creators to see their
dream and obviously there's always a lot
of talk especially now about diversity
and inclusion do you thought sylheti to
bring diverse filmmakers and people
behind the cameras and as well as
diverse story interesting thing I mean
if people look outside of themselves and
at the world at large and then allow for
different voices to come into their zone
then it would be inclusive and you would
broad spectrum of who we are as a world
and I think we get so closed off into
our little zones of people that we you
know I don't think it's an intentional
thing but yeah we adore you we can't
wait to see you in there congratulations
on the award thanks everybody so much
for watching we have been here at the
31st annual Producers Guild of America
Awards red carpet now things are winding
down on the red carpet but our girl
lauren zima is actually headed backstage
to catch with the night's big winners
you can catch all those interviews on ET
online.com and of course ET live thank
you all so much for watching and of
course check out Entertainment Tonight
our broadcast show covers everything to
do with award season and all the big
stars study thank you so much Thank You
Lauren all right cheers everybody thanks
for watching